France is Banning Muslim Students from
wearing the abay in state-run schools
the full length robe often worn by
Muslim women has caused much debate on
whether it should be allowed in French
schools the education Minister now says
that new guidelines will be issued
before classes resume next
week Public Schools must at any cost
perhaps more than any other institution
be protected from religious
indoctrination or from the refusal of
our most important common
rules and let's take this on we can
speak now to lbar rig who's National
president of the EMF Muslim Students of
France joins us from rube in France lbna
welcome to alaz good to have you with us
this is all causing huge consternation
isn't it but the bottom line is the iara
is not actually an item of religious
clothing uh hello thank you for inviting
me uh that's true uh Abaya is known to
not be uh a religious government it's
actually a cultural one anyone who does
an internet research can see that uh
although the government don't seem to
really care about this information uh
and still ban it which is interesting
because what we see is that um alongside
Afghanistan and Iran France is the only
are the only country that legislate on
the clothing that women can and cannot
wear but what which women are they uh
legering on it's Muslim women it's women
from
immigration and this shows how this is
like inher inherently racist because
when you decide that a dress a simple
dress ANM dress this actually was uh
given in multiple reports uh hm dress
are actually seen as problematic but
which which girl who are wearing them
are seen as as problematic the one who
are for example from an Arabic
background the one who are black but
never would they stop a white girl for
example wearing this so it's quite an so
so what do you say when when you hear
the the education Minister saying that
the religion of school pupils should not
be
identifiable from what they're
wearing you know this is actually it
actually shows what I just said because
you know there was like a testimony
showing that um a Headmaster said you
don't need to see if it to know what
is just look at the students and you're
going to know when it's worn and when
it's not what does that mean that mean
that it's just about who is wearing it
and actually even sometimes when the
student is not even someone who wears
the hijab they still stop them it's on
the ground when you look at it because
it's it has been a quite a debate for
some times now it will slate in
harassment on Muslim of Muslim Students
we are talking about head Masters
chasing up students in highways or or
teacher waiting every every morning for
the Muslims students to control their
outfits or even condition their access
to the classroom uh if they don't have
shorter outfits for example for sport if
your t-shirt is not short enough uh it's
actually a professor that said that if
it's not short enough if I cannot see
the downside you are not you are refused
you cannot enter how does this all tie
into the ban of the head
scarf excuse me can you repeat how does
all this tie in with the ban of the head
scarf yeah um so for those who don't
know in 2024 there was a rule uh that
was stated that uh students cannot show
any um religious sign in schools primary
school middle and high school um to be
honest uh when they chose this uh when
they decided to uh enforce this law uh
firstly it was ultimately it was towards
Muslim and especially Veil uh hijab uh
as a g
so how is it linked I would say it's
just a Pandora box that was opened in
2024 when you say okay every religious
religious sign is uh not accepted and
then a few years later it was about
bandana okay but is bana hij not and
then now it's dresses but what is it
going to be in the future is it going to
be like I don't know earrings is is it
going to be uh I don't know what's next
makeup underwear actually that was a
question that Headmaster asked one of
the student what do you have under youra
is it a normal underwear or is it
something else so it shows that it's
just it's not Linked In A logical manner
is just a crazy racism and a crazy
islamophobia that just every time find a
new thing to look into and to chase okay
we'll leave it there Alig uh speaking to
us from ru in France thank
you thank you